if you're interested in making quality
Investments this is for you thanks to St
media Rocky spoke with Glenn Martin to
talk about what alternative Investments
are and how their company is changing
the investing game now you're Chris
Martin but introduce us to Glenn Martin
okay well Glenn Martin's my grandfather
companies started over 100 years ago
actually we celebrated history our
history in 2019 but we've changed a lot
over the years today our focus is
growing new and developing new
opportunities in the private Equity
space so it's a we have a variety of
asset classes that we work on uh real
estate is probably the biggest area that
we focus on but we also look at uh
Enterprise opportunities with stable
cash flows okay and another word I guess
you could say is you you're focused on
alternative Investments can you explain
that concept for for people watching
alternative Investments uh you know are
a little different than traditional
stocks bonds or cash type Investments
um Alternatives generally fall into this
area if I've heard of probably hedge
funds private Equity venture capital or
some other real assets So within the
private Equity space face you've you've
got investment funds which are
classified as either real estate or
maybe an Enterprise acquisition so so
that that's generally the the the field
of what alternatives come you're
Building A New Concept in luxury home
ownership so let's talk about that new
Venture for for you guys at Glen Martin
we started this concept about two years
ago uh with the start of a new home we
built in San Miguel de Allende Mexico uh
the home is now up and operating we have
an operator uh running that home kubei
International is operating at home
um so the concept around this program is
to
support uh homes that are valued that at
least five million generally the the the
the the values between 10 to 15 million
dollars on the homes uh and generate
rental homes income streams as I
operated home so it's a it's an
interesting concept it's not something
new necessarily but we are we are
launching this in markets that are
generally underserved in Latin America
so Chris how can the Las Vegas community
help you and how can you help us our
investment center here in Downtown
Dallas I I you know what's cool we're
actually filming from that location
right now and
um so we've set up a really amazing
place where we can produce high quality
videos here talk about what we invested
and what we do but it's not just for our
use it's a community tool we invite the
community to support this facility and
so no matter what the cool part is is it
no matter where you're at you can have
uh you can you can play a role
participating in dancing you think that
eventually these kinds of facilities
might exist all over the world
connecting people from other parts of
the world to a Locale like Las Vegas or
Dallas or wherever you're locally
located uh and bringing International
investors to those communities
our thanks to St media for sponsoring
this segment if you'd like more
information on Glenn Martin head to the
website on your screen we'll be right
back
[Music]